- Good morning, Believe Nation.
Today's message is don't complain!
Over to you, Manny Pacquiao.
[Rooster Crowing]
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entpresso keep me going
- How do you think that
impacted you growing up,
not having your dad around?
- Um, actually, I'm not blaming my dad.
It's, uh,
it's good for us
that our dad is not around
because we're not relying on our dad.
We learn how to work hard,
because we're all boys,
so we learn how to work hard
and to make money,
in, you know,
in a nice way.
And that's how we get strong.
- People who complain, they lose at life.
They lose at life!
Look at the people who
complain the most around you.
Look at your friends, look at your family,
look at the people in your circle.
The ones who just are
non-stop complainers,
you know who those people are,
chances are they are the
least successful people
in your network.
People who complain don't rise up.
It doesn't happen.
You look at the top people
in any field
they take action on complaints.
They make money off of complainers.
They build businesses around complainers.
Entrepreneurs see a
problem, and what do we do?
What do we do? We solve it.
That's what entrepreneurs do.
While other people are
too busy complaining
about their problems,
entrepreneurs see that and say,
hey, hm, this problem kind of sucks.
And other people are probably
going through the same thing,
the more people have that problem,
the bigger the opportunity is for you.
I look at my own story as an example.
In my very first business,
the founder started the company,
I joined later as an owner,
because he had a problem in his laboratory
and he wanted software to help him fix it.
So it was designed around his own need.
I look at my YouTube channel that you guys
are well aware of, since
you're watching this video,
I didn't want to make these videos.
I didn't want to have to do this.
I wanted to consume content
from famous entrepreneurs.
I wanted to be around successful people,
because I felt like the people around me
weren't having the kind
of success that I wanted,
and so I wanted to surround
myself with this daily.
And there wasn't really
good content on YouTube.
There was tons of videos on YouTube,
but not the content that I wanted,
and I had to sit through
10 hours of an Elon Musk,
you know, interview series to
get the couple good points.
So I wanted it to be easier.
And instead of complaining
that this didn't exist,
I decided to make it.
I made it and I shared it,
and it was great for me
and hopefully it's great for you,
you guys are enjoying the content,
and learning, and
getting inspired as well.
I just wanted to be a consumer,
I wish that problem didn't exist.
I wish I could just
go, turn on my computer
and boom, there's amazing
content for me to consume.
And enjoy, and uplift myself,
and learn something from.
But it didn't exist and so I made it.
And so the next time you catch yourself
either complaining yourself, stop it.
Okay? Stop it, stop complaining.
Look for a solution,
look for an opportunity,
because that may become
a business thing for you.
And if you are hanging around people
who are just complaining,
complaining, complaining,
and complaining, don't
let them bring you down.
Don't let their negativity bring you down.
You are a product of your environment.
And if you're hanging
around positive, uplifting,
insightful, thoughtful
things, people, videos
that's what you will become.
And if you're hanging around
negative complaining, whining individuals,
that's what you're going to become.
So choose wisely, and stop complaining.
So the question of the day today is,
I'm curious,
what was one complaint that you turned
into an opportunity for yourself?
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm super curious to see
what you guys have to say.
I also want to give a quick shout-out
to Terrance Robertson-Fall,
thank you so much Terrance for picking up
a copy of my book Your One Word,
it really, really,
really means a lot to me
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching,
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is!
Much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot
of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning!
♫ Entspresso keep me going.
- I'm a pretty happy guy!
- [Interviewer] Yeah, so just--
- You know, I think that's
one of the keys to success.
I read in an article that
the difference between successful people
and people that struggle
are successful people exude joy.
Jeff, if you're not a happy guy,
and other people don't
want to hang out with you,
why would they hang out with you?
- Right.
- If you're miserable,
and nobody wants to spend time with you,
how're you ever going to get ahead?
- Yeah, it's true.
- Why complain?
I remember when we were really young,
this lesson was taught to me by my dad,
and I kind of had a
miserable day at school,
cause you know, the kids make fun of you,
you're an immigrant, you're poor.
And I came home and I was
feeling sorry for myself,
and my dad came home,
this is going to sound so melodramatic,
he walked a couple miles to the factory
he was blue collar guy,
and I came home, and I just stood there,
and I was complaining about my day.
- Where were you living?
- Oh, we were living in like a, oh,
this stage would be three times the size,
in a little apartment.
- [Jeff] Oh my gosh!
- [Robert] It wasn't, it wasn't pleasant.
And my dad was just standing there,
and I was complaining and
feeling sorry for myself,
and my dad looks at me and says,
never complain.
You should always be happy
with the opportunities given you.
And that was it.
[Audience Applause]
- You know, you feel that big.
- How many of you have ever
complained in your life?
[Audience Laughter]
- Yeah, and here's what I've
learned about complaining.
In order to complain,
I have to have reference point
of something better that I want
that I'm not willing to risk creating.
Now, let me explain that again.
I have to have a reference
point in my mind,
of something I want
that's better than what I have,
that I'm not willing to risk creating,
so what I do is complain about it instead.
See, if I was complaining about my wife,
it would mean that I'd have to believe
that somewhere out there in the world,
there's a better woman than my wife.
See, if every woman on the planet died,
except my wife,
do you think I'd go to work the next day
and complain about her?
[Audience Laughter]
- No, she's the only one!
And I'd be going, hey, and I got her,
this is really cool, right?
[Audience Laughter]
- Do you ever hear anyone
complain about gravity?
Very rarely!
You know, gravity makes us all bend over,
do you ever see an old
person going down the street
going Gravity!
They have a little walker: I hate gravity!
If it weren't for gravity,
I wouldn't be all bent over like this.
Gravity sucks!
No, have you ever heard
an older person doing it?
No, the reason they don't
complain about gravity
is because there's no alternative to it.
You know, gravity just is.
So if someone's complaining
about something,
it means they know
there's something they can do about it.
Because we don't complain
about the things we can't change.
So as soon as you hear
yourself complaining,
I want you to stop and say,
okay, what would I rather have?
Remember, law of attraction always says
focus on what you want
not what you don't want.
'Cause when you're talking
about what you don't want,
when you're complaining and blaming,
you're focusing on that
which you don't want,
and you're accelerating
it's expression out
into the universe with
those negative feelings.
And yet we'll spend a majority of our time
complaining about so many things.
And usually, we complain
about them to people
who can't do anything about it.
- Another thing that you can do,
is never, ever complain.
When I see people
complaining, I'm just like,
What are you doing?
Like, your life is so short,
are you really going to
sit here complaining.
Let me put this in perspective, okay?
I'm 34, okay, I'm 34, now in my twenties
I didn't know that many
people that died, okay?
As you start to hit 30,
people start to die, okay?
I had a friend that died last week, okay?
People are just going
to start dying, okay?
I've also almost died
myself a couple times.
Who here in this room
has almost died before?
Put your hands up.
Look at that, look at that crowd,
now, if that many people have almost died,
let me be a little morbid
and freak out here,
how many people weren't here
to put their hands up?
There's probably like
little ghosts of people
like, I actually did die,
like, right in this crowd right now.
That is going to be you, okay?
You are going to be dead soon enough.
So don't waste your
time complaining, okay?
Don't waste your time complaining.
It is a terrible, terrible idea, alright?
So basically, what you want to do is like,
never be negative, never complain.